hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba what
is your name
a Chara Kirk Asher and I are doing
videos alone right now that's never
happened before
yeah I have a constant tension in my
right shoulder due to it because it's
like oh this is new uncomfortable
transition we're gonna watch the sisters
brothers trailer that's hard this is a
true story I feel like you would go with
that funny title only if it was a true
story it's a Western
starring Gyllenhaal and a few other
familiar faces if I'm not mistaken I
love westerns grew up on them oh yeah
did you I didn't but my dad left
westerns well I don't know how he failed
to spread that love but I like country
music yeah you should have gone with the
Western walking phoenixes whoa we need
to get out open the store together
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my father drink interesting what's a
great challenge at all prospector sticks
how do I get the goals just beneath my
feet I told you once chemist
yes wow you hit me I slap you you slap
you back I think that is instantly
climbing up to one of my top 10 most
anticipated movies so far this year that
looks like it's total delight of a film
I like kind of this new age of westerns
that we're getting they kind of have
this more fun vibe about the trail the
trailers always having a cool vibe and
I've been playing the video game Red
Dead Redemption oh yeah and I'm more
than halfway through it now since I've
been playing that I'm like this this is
exactly what I'm in the mood for right
now really badass Western what do you
think I have to say in the beginning I
thought for a second that the trailer
was broken that's really cool with the
gunshots and then it has the words
appear whether that was really a field
immersive the cost is really funny I
wasn't expecting that wasn't expecting
the humor like john c reilly seems to be
more of the role that I thought Joaquin
Phoenix might have played Joaquin
Phoenix seems a lot goofier yes where
john c reilly I would imagine him to be
more of the goofy one and they're
walking in Phoenix is more of like the
straightforward kind of badass one but I
get the impression walking in Phoenix
might be the older one I'm kind of
confused on which one's the older
brother or not because that whole thing
about the slap well the older brother
would slap and the younger wooden slab
that's why he's pissed because the
younger brothers
oh okay is that what it is well that as
an older sister if my younger sister
slapped me I'd be like oh you did not oh
my god I am so embarrassed all right oh
yeah yeah
Joaquin Phoenix must be the younger one
who's younger the dynamics of them being
flipped is what I like
Riz Ahmed and Jake Gyllenhaal are
playing different types of characters in
that time you got the outlaw characters
and then you got like the prospect
people looking for gold characters their
demeanor and dynamic is a totally
different part of the the southern
Western vibe as well they're a little
more proper so I'm excited to see their
interplay because it looks funny but it
doesn't look like a comedy it still
feels like a western movie that has
humor yeah if there's one thing I
probably would have liked a little more
of in this trailer is some of the
Western action scenes you'll get if
there are any I imagine there will be
especially because of the opening having
kind of this stylish way going about it
I guess I would have liked a little bit
more of a tease on that but in terms of
like the characters and the dynamics
this looks like a really fun time yeah
it looks like a fun run man rum rum rum
rum rum romp a rum you know it's funny
Riz Ahmed is in venom and Jake
Gyllenhaal is gonna be Mysterio in
spider-man and Joaquin Phoenix might be
the Joker and john c reilly was in
guardians of the galaxy oh my god
connection it's cool to see Joaquin
Phoenix and Jake Gyllenhaal in the same
movie together two of the best actors
around who are not Oscar what hurts me
and also the name of the gang the
sisters brothers I mean it makes sense
now that it was kind of explained in the
trailer their last name is sisters yeah
bizarre I wonder how many jokes are
gonna come from that oh yeah I mean I
can relate my name is Greg Alba look
Jessica yeah yeah like Jessica the super
talented actress alright guys well you
can subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification Malka subscribe
buttons don't work and you can check out
a Chara on the get Jabby channel
reactions and stuff too it's almost the
exact same thing
and you could chill so check us out on
patreon full-length TV show reactions
whacked like you and I it's music video
coverage there's a whole bunch of
goodies over there would love to have
you become a paper on eject today